unsere große frage stellt sich wie
kommen unsere gastronomen jetzt durch
den herbst und durch den winter sie
haben einen drei punkte plan aufgestellt
also einen vorschlag an die gastronomen
fangen wir mal bei punkt eins an herr
professor ja also punkt eins ist
natürlich nach wie vor die maske da
kommen wir nicht drum herum
aber so wie es jetzt in den restaurants
und gaststätten ganz habt wird dass man
wenn man dann tisch sitzt und natürlich
dann essen und isst und trinkt dann muss
man natürlich die maske nicht ob haben
aber soweit meine tisch verlässt beim
hereinkommen oder auch beim
toilettengang dann muss man die maske
aufsetzt das wäre also der punkt 1 und
dann kommen wir auch direkt zu punkt 2
ja also punkt zwei ist dass man die
möglichkeit ihr hat auch die luft die
möglicherweise angereichert ist also
jetzt in einem restaurant ohne babbel
dass man die entsprechenden filtern da
gibt es inzwischen sehr gute filter
geräte in verschiedensten größen die in
entsprechendem umfang auch die luft
filtern kann so dass wir praktisch
sterilen luft wieder bekommen man muss
dann nur das richtig berechnet auch die
größe auf die kubikmeter die wir da
haben und dann wird die luft so
umgesetzt so durch den filter gezogen
das sterile luft rauskommt das ist eine
erhebliche
begünstigung dann fielen innenraum und
punkt 3 hat ja was mit der mundspülung
zu tun klären sie sich da auf genau das
hatten wir schon mal erklärt der nasen
rachenraum ist halt der ort in dem sich
die krone viren vermehren und von dort
aus sonst würden wir auch nicht die
maske tragen müssen von dort aus werden
sie eben weiter fahrzeit durch sprechen
husten niesen und so weiter wenn wir
beim eintritt bzw vor dem einzelnen in
ein restaurant das würde aber genauso
auch gelten vielleicht für ein theater
oder für ein kino eine desinfizierende
mundspülung durchführen also eine minute
muss man dann eben schon mal warten und
führt dort diese desinfektion der
mundhöhle durch dann ist man mindestens
für diesen abend frei von corona viren
die ansteckungsfähigkeit wir reduzieren
die viren in unserer mühle so stark dass
wir in dieser zeit praktisch nichts mehr
ausscheiden können das wäre auch eine
variante weil man dir kontrollieren kann
das kann der gast float organisieren und
das am eingang eben so eine kleine
mundspülung stattfindet das ist schnell
gemacht und damit ist man natürlich auf
der ganz sicheren seite weil man die
große zahl der viren reduziert und dann
nur noch ganz wenige übrig bleiben weil
ist praktisch nicht mehr ansteckend
mehr nachrichten und bikinis nur weil
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren